[Musique]
à
pour les malaises d'or sont nommés
gilles verdez à chérie je t'aime parce
que tu es mon coeur tu es mon âme tu es
mon corps alors fatto mon amour est ce
que tu veux m'épouser
il faut bien
[Applaudissements]
oh
jean michel lemaire
iliad où il ya la stratégie et d'émotion
photo m alors c'est une super épreuve
mais ça n'a aucun intérêt c'est à lui de
rester 32 35 minutes devant devant deux
personnes debout sur un poteau vois tu
as bien deux cherchent une coupe dodge
[Applaudissements]
matthieu delormeau
alors je vais vous dire j'avais le choix
entre croquer un oignon ou embrasser
matthieu delormeau et donc depuis le
début tu aurais bien entendu choisi non
[Applaudissements]
l'équipe ii plateaux
[Musique]
c'est pas du tout ça va montrer qu'elle
a beau match plein d'autres matières il
est meurtri
va-t-il à [ __ ]
thierry moreau n'est pas gbagbo village
vous savez ce qu'on dit jeanne d'arc
elle a free il a tout compris
merci chaud bouillant dauphin
et valérie bénaïm
vous avez un amour aux primaires quand
il s'appelait au primaire j'avais un
amour
monsieur quand vous appelez philippe m
et ça a mis tous mes mecs un cours de
récréation certainement en sixième puis
à sarcelles mais jamais été à l'école
nassar serge tu désolé monsieur très
affaibli par ce qui s'est passé entre
philippe
[Applaudissements]
sa chair juteuse de voter pour le
malaise d'or qui des chroniqueurs va
remporter deux malaises leur spécialité
pmp on aura la réponse en fin d'émission